members of the anti-trump resistance are
delighting tonight in a new war of words
between Steve Bannon and President Trump
which the left is hoping is going to
breathe life into that flagging baller
Russia collusion investigation in a
soon-to-be published book about the
first year of the trump presidency been
and suggests that President Trump was
aware of that controversial June 2016
meeting between Don junior and a Russian
attorney at Trump Tower Bannon says
reportedly the chance that Don junior
did not walk these people up to his
father's office is zero by the way it's
worth noting that Bannon didn't actually
join the campaign until August of 2016
two months after that meeting occurred
well as you can imagine all of this set
off a Pavlovian feeding frenzy in the
media since bannon's account contradicts
the statements of the White House
officials who've claimed that the
president never was told about that
meeting and Bannon goes on to
characterize the Trump Tower meeting as
both treasonous and unpatriotic he
predicted that Muller's team will quote
crack Don junior like an egg
ouch the president's son-in-law Jared
Kushner was also called out by Bannon
and he said you realize where this is
going this is all about money-laundering
mother shows senior prosecutor Andrew
Weissman first and he's a
money-laundering guy their path to
blanking Trump goes right through Paul
manna for Don jr. and Jared Kushner it's
as plain as a hair on your face the
president responded in a typically blunt
statement he said Steve Bannon has
nothing to do with me and my presidency
when he was fired he not only lost his
job he lost his mind
Steve doesn't represent my base he's
only in it for himself okay here's my
advice and the form of a few questions
I'm kind of playing a little bit of a
you know dr. Phil maybe a little Judge
Judy here some questions who does this
help does this kind of unseemly
tit-for-tat advance the conservative
populist agenda at all what's going
through frankly both sides minds
now Donald Trump is the head of the
Republican Party it's not Bannon it's
not me it's Donald Trump and with these
statements Bannon is given basically
credence to the worst conspiracy
theories of the impeach Trump forces
bandits probably won himself a trip to
testify on Capitol Hill as well and is
that really what Dannan wants I mean I
know Steve bans that what he wants if
there is a policy difference between
Bannon and Trump on any issue or any of
us with the administration on any issue
have a substantive exchange rally the
voters to your point of view on whatever
issue it happens to be but fellas it
doesn't really make sense for a high
profile advisor and its former boss to
publicly attack each other when the
stakes are this high how does that make
any sense and aren't you kind of playing
right into the hands of the Democrats
and the media who are hoping for nothing
more than your mutually assured
destruction ironically what bannon's
comments again if accurate have actually
done they've kind of created a tidal
wave of establishment support for
President Trump they're all rallying to
his side today not exactly how we saw
this story developing now on to more
important matters there was a big
meeting with congressional leaders of
both parties at the White House today on
a potential deal to give legal status to
the 800,000 so-called dreamers brought
into the country by their parents or
sent to the country on their own and
it's a negotiation that's scheduled to
continue tomorrow the president's going
to be really involved tomorrow in that
meeting I understand and as you'll
recall Obama through an executive action
is called deferred action on childhood
arrivals daca he allowed all these
people to stay and ultimately work in
the country for a rolling two year
periods you can you can read up after
every two-year period in fact in 2017
even during the Trump administration
tens of thousands of illegal dreamers
applied for and did receive their daca
status so in a way
Obama's policy lived on but last
September Trump said he would end the
program but then and what was kind of a
game of hot potato illegal alien style
he gave Congress six months to find
their own solution kind of smart
actually
but Trump demanded that lawmakers pass
responsible immigration reform as part I
guess as part of all this so what might
responsible immigration reform look like
well the president has given us a few
clues already this kid came in through a
lottery system they've already
instructed Congress they must end it he
talked about he verified building the
wall chain migration which is a huge all
those things are happening we're gonna
have to do a verify chain migration is
that a requirement for you to chain
migration is a disaster for this country
and it's going to end it be part of a
dreamer deal that's a deal it'll be part
of a daca deal well the president's on
the right track here and as I said last
night there must be non negotiables for
any daca deal I'm frankly concerned
about any daca deal but if it's gonna
happen we must fully fund the border
wall we must end chain migration we must
defend the sanctuary cities we must end
the visa lottery
we must mandate a verify hire thousands
more immigration and ice agents to
enforce the law in immigration judges by
the way and cut the number of green card
recipients by half the dreamer nightmare
by the way is it's already upon us I
love how they use the word dreamers like
none of the rest of us have dreams
dreamers actually will cost the American
taxpayer 2.6 billion dollars annually if
Congress passes amnesty that's according
to the Congressional Budget Office not
me and more unaccompanied alien children
are coming across now today why are they
doing that why are the numbers going up
of the unaccompanied minors because
Congress is flirting with granting
citizenship to dreamers and all the
benefits of health care education
housing so foreigners see the green
light here according to the last two
months of available stats
we've seen a surge this is how bad it is
7,000 unaccompanied children have
crossed the border and by the way they
cannot be deported to their home country
under current US law they get to stay
here they're sent out to there they're
detained initially then they're released
into the u.s. becoming our
responsibility the US taxpayer is
responsibility given that we have just
think about this is this one metric
thousands of homeless US veterans on the
streets tonight shivering in the cold
with no one to care for them suffering
from PTSD mental illness addiction
problems by the way about two hundred
yards from where I'm broadcasting right
now we have them in the streets at a
homeless shelter when they can't get in
they're out in the streets but we're
catering to the illegal immigrants
that's the priority of Congress Mille in
a moment we're going to explain the
demographic political and cultural
effects of illegal immigration that have
swept and by the way could swamp the
country the failure of Republicans to
protect and secure the border cost them
dearly at the ballot box for several
cycles and their perpetual efforts to
cater to the violators of our laws at
the expense of working citizens and
legal immigrants are one of the reasons
that Donald Trump got elected in the
first place remember it's called America
first and if Republicans make some
quickie deal on daca some cutesy thing
they pull and violate the president's
promised is base it'll be GOP last and
that's the angle